[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maccabi et bilal et les jingle
aujourd'hui sans rigoler écoutez je peux
faire parler nice en écoutant le jingle
alors gérald il ya plein de choses sur
twitter qui demandent des nouvelles
d'ovni géraldine et les glisser bêtement
elle a glissé ben gourion moi alors je
vous donne un conseil l'échec quand des
trucs sont balancés la meilleure chose à
faire c'est de ne pas bouger fait courir
là exactement fait comme kanye règles
élémentaires et regardez elle ne panique
jamais elle ne bouge pas franchement ne
paniquez pas d'accord c'est la règle
d'or le elle ne bouge pas elle voulait
dire un peu je veux garder mon emploi
s'ils tablent à cyril et ne bougerait
pas très sympa aller très sympa
attention est laissée par cabella bluff
la cabine est là maintenant elle est
magnifique voyez ce rideau qu'on
achetait encore cet après-midi le
magnifique se révéler très bon alors on
doit regarder à qui ah ouais d'accord et
ce cas là c'est dans leurs minables la
cud kabila blog ce soir ah oui alors je
peux regarder je te plaît alors on va
vous dire ce qu'ils voient dans la
cabine à bluff
djamel va de vous dire ce qu'il voit
nominé six mois je vais voir aussi les
chroniqueurs elle est chronique et qui
sont payés jaloux dire ce que vous voyez
dans la cabine à bord
c'est magnifique je suis sûr que chez
vous senna l'égérie vous rêvez de voir
ce qu'il adore à kasserine des meilleurs
cabinets c'est petit lait tout et son
folk pourquoi parce qu'elle est en deux
temps toujours tu as vu ça aussi moi
j'ai fait moins appel à revoir c'est
incroyable alors un coup à à à lundi ils
sont deux à votre avis on va pas vous
faire de propositions on a tellement
rigolé à votre avis qui va dans la
famille noble dans la cabine à bluff
bernard ou deux noms elle est dans le
film
non c'est raté j'ai raté plutôt boudeur
alors bouder ah c'est pas une réponse
c'est très exaltant
ouais ouais l'approximatif c'est
approximatives ou d'art avec ramzy avec
ramzy on est sur un duo de cet acabit
mais non nous viennent avec eric judor
désolé j'ai pas vous faire attendre plus
longtemps
ceux qui sont là ils sont dans le film
ils sont exceptionnels aussi c'est
bouder le conseil
c'est un autre indice ils sont deux dont
un animal un petit animal poilus
regardez ces bouder et walid
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bull rb5 jamel debbouze cavallari